[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
grand JIT nous reviendrons sur les
conséquences des tempêtes qui se sont
succédées sur le littoral atlantique
inondation coupure d'électricité et une
rideau potable qui ont des effets à long
terme sur l'agriculture c'est ce qu'a pu
constater notre partenaire TBO en
Bretagne qu'il pleuve ou qu'il ventent
les livreurs à vélo sont là pour nous
tous leur statut a donné son nom à une
nouvelle forme de précarité
luubérisation au moment où leur
situation est examinée par la commission
européenne six d'entre eux ont pris la
route vers Bruxelles pour obtenir de
meilleures conditions de travail
ou notre partenaire les a rencontré
selon une étude de nos ordinateurs
téléphone et Data Center génère plus de
gaz à effet de serre que l'aviation
civile et oui une start-up du man innve
vous allez voir avec un système de
refroidissement LMTV Sart nous
l'expliquera dans un instant et puis
attention à vos papis c'est l'épice la
plus chère du monde la récolte de l'or
rouge se déroule en ce moment même et
demande une grande minutie la France
produit une dizaines de kilos de safran
chaque année et via occitan s'est rendu
dans une
safranière
depuis 20 jours les passages successifs
des tempêtes kan et Domingo sont
entraînés des inondations dans le pas
decalais comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images tournées par les équipes de
Weo TV la chaîne de la voie du Nord ses
cru qualifié d'historique par les
services de météoance ont inondé une
soixantaine de communes autour de
Boulogne surmer et de Saint-Omer
entraînant des coupures d'électricité
d'alimentation en eau potable de
suspension de lignes ferroviaires de
routes coupée et de fermeture d'écoles
selon les premières è estimations la
tempête cararane va causer entre 370 et
480 millions d'euros de dégâts et les
assureurs ont étendu la période de
déclaration des sinistres jusqu'au 1er
décembre 2023 soit 30 jours après le
passage de la tempête voilà et pour être
tout à fait complet sur ces tempêtes
300000 habitants ont été touchés sur le
million et demi d'habitants que compte
le Pas de
Calais ces phénomènes climatiques ont
perturbé l'alimentation en eau potable
alors si dans les commune sinistrée les
mairies ont organisé des distributions
de bouteilles pour certains éleveurs il
a fallu résoudre au plus vite le manque
d'eau qui faisait plané une menace sur
la survie de leurs animaux c'est un
reportage d'éenora le nôtre pour TBO sur
place c'est là les dégâts principaux sur
la toiture du coup nos Génis sont dans
les courants d'air dans la Ferme de
Marie aussi la tempête Kane a laissé une
trace de son passage un morceau du toit
s'est envolé et l'agricultrice doit
aujourd'hui trouver une solution pour
éviter que ces vaches ne passent l'hiver
dans le froid mais ce bâtiment endommagé
n'est pas le seul dégât provoqué par la
tempête la famille d'agriculteur doit
faire face à une autre préoccupation
voilà un des bacao qu'on a installé pour
les vaches laitières on en a mis un sur
chaque herpaillé et le premier jour les
pompiers nous ont ravitaillé en eau
parce que le plus gros problème c'est
l'accès à l'eau potable depuis jeudi une
partie de la commune de plonévet du Fou
n'a plus accès à l'eau potable la mairie
distribue des bouteilles au particulier
mais pour les exploitations agricoles
qui nécessitent de gros volumes d'eau
l'heure est à la débrouille une
vachtière ça boit 80 à 100 L d'eau par
jour on en a à peu près 80 vachesétièr
du coup ça fait une grosse quantité
d'eau par jour à leur fournir et la
solidarité c'est organisé les pompiers
sont venus nous livrer avec leur citne
de 4000 L le premier jour et maintenant
on va chez des voisins qui ont un forage
et on envoie notre tonne ào on la charge
là-bas et on fait des allers-retours
comme ça toute la J journée un réseau
d'entraide s'est créé dans la commune
Aurore leemigne possède depuis quelques
années un forage sur son exploitation
elle n'a pas subi de coupure d'eau et
propose aux exploitants des environs de
venir s'approvisionner on a fortement
l'habitude et c'est un réseau qui est
assez présent en milieu agricole que ça
soit ben pour les problèmes d'eau de
problèmes d'alimentation électrique ou
autre en cette période-ci ça reste
toujours solidaire dans le Finistère
plusieurs communes manque d'eau en cause
les coupures d'électricité qui ont
empêché les station de production d'eau
potable de
fonctionner voilà plus à l'ouest les
effets de la tempête Domingo sont encore
difficiles à mesurer pour les
austrculteurs du bassin d'Arcachon
notamment mais en début de semaine ils
ont pu tirer un premier bilan très
inquiétant du passage de la tempête qui
a ravagé le ban d'Arguin cette bande de
sable située à la pointe du Cap Ferré
Franck poireau était sur place pour TV7
la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest et là il y
a plus que du 4 et du 5 et à peine de
trois de la moyenne ce qui se vend le
plus à Noël des huîtres de petite taille
c'est tout ce qu' a pu récupérer cet
austrioculteur de Guan Mestras sur sa
concession du ban d'Arguin la semaine
dernière le sud de cette langue de sable
située à l'entrée du bassin a été
particulièrement touché par la tempête
Céline elle a enfoui sous plusieurs
dizaines de centimètres de sable
plusieurs milliers de poches à huîre
Alain pouet de basque a réussi à sauver
la moitié de sa production du ban
d'Arguin soit 4000 tonnes il se demande
aujourd'hui dans quel état il va
retrouver ses parcs à après le passage
de la tempête de Mingo on a juste à
espérer là maintenant mais on peut pas
on attend de voir là j'ai j'ai Noël qui
est en jeu c'est c'est clair et net il
est impossible pour le moment à cause
des coefficients de Maré trop bas de se
rendre sur le band d'Arguin jeudi
dernier sur place les austrculteurs
estimaient que 20 hectares de parc
austricol sur les 45 que compte cette
langue de sable ont disparu après le
passage de la tempête Céline soit près
d'une centaine de parcelles la parcelle
est perdue c'estàdire la la la capacité
à continuer à produire à cet endroitlà
c'est perdu donc oui c'est une perte moi
ma priorité c'est c'est c'est c'est de
sauver que les entreprise sauve la
production qu'on nettoie le ban Marien
jeudi il restait beaucoup de travail de
austriculteurs pour tenter de sauver ce
qui peut l'être sur la partie sud du
band d'Arguin le passage de Domingo a
peut-être accentuer les dégâts on a
aussi des évaluations à mener sur le
reste du bassin les coefficients de Maré
devraient permettre aussi d'accéder à
l'ensemble des zones austréicoles du
bassin
d'Arcachon le 13 octobre dernier
Dominique Bernard était victime du
terrorisme la présence et la visibilité
des soldats de l'opé sentinelle ont
depuis été renforcé sur tout le
territoire depuis 2015 ils sont ainsi
plus de 10000 militaires engagés pour
protéger les Français pour TL7 dans la
Loire Anthony verpillon a accompagné une
patrouille dans les rues de
Saint-Étienne regardez et ce lundi matin
ce sont donc deux groupes de quatre
militaires et leurs lieutenants qui
partent patrouiller en centr-eville de
Saint-Étienne ces légionnaires sont
déployés pour quelques semaines dans le
département de la Loire une présence qui
rassure et s'avère bien souvent dis
nous sommes assez bien acceptés même on
nous encourage assez régulièrement suite
aux patrouilles Saint-Étienne ça reste
une ville comme une autre comme une
autre ville du du continent la menace
est autant avérée ici qu'ailleurs des
hommes lourdement armés qui
n'hésiteraient d'ailleurs pas à faire
usage de leur armes en cas de besoin
nous sommes autorisés à ouvrir le feu
comme comme sur un territoire en
opération extérieure l'opération
sentinelle qui mobilise 3 7000
militaires dans toute la France depuis
les attentats de 2015 et même si la loi
ronséré comme un désert militaire à
l'instar d'une quarantaine de
départements français sans régiment sur
leur territoire sentinelle est devenu
incontournable chez nous alors dans la
Loire je ne vous dirai pas exactement
combien de militaires sont sont déployés
parce que déjà c'est un dispositif qui
est très mouvant et très fluctuant donc
ça peut aller de quelques dizaines de
personnel militaire à plusieurs dizaines
et plusieurs centaines de personnels
militaires en fonction de en fonction
des événements notez enfin que ces
militaires sont placés sous l'autorité
du préfet de la Loire en ce moment les
lieux de culte sont particulièrement
surveillés Roberto Balzaretti ne CRA ni
la pluie ni le froid entre mars 2022 et
jusqu'à la fin de l'année l'ambassadeur
de Suisse en France sillonne les routes
de l'Hexagone à vélo 13 étapes de
plusieurs jours ont été imaginées avec
un seul objectif partir à la rencontre
des régions françaises des acteurs et
des institutions qui façonnent au
quotidien la relation atéral
franco-suisse il a fait étape à limoge
et Alain druau l'a rencontré pour notre
partenaire C à limoge sur place déjà il
restera beaucoup de de souvenirs de
lieux de personnes rencontrées ensuite
il restera cahier d'adresse très très
large qu'il faudra soigner et une
occasion ça c'est la troisième chose
d'approfondir davantage cette amitié
franco-suisse donc il restera du travail
parce qu'il faudra continuer de
construire sur les rencontres euh qu'on
aura eu restons à bicyclette nous avons
tous un jour ou l'autre fait appel au
service d'un livreur à vélo si le
service est rentrer dans les murs les
conditions de travail de ces
travailleurs indépendants sont en débat
à Bruxelles six livreurs à vélo de CIN
nationalités différentes ont donc décidé
de parcourir 384 km entre Paris et
Bruxelles en cinq étapes pour effectuer
la grande livraison une livraison qui a
pour but de dénoncer la dégradation des
conditions de travail des coursiers à
vélo auto entrepreneur et défendre un
projet de directive européenne qui
prévoit de transformer les travailleurs
des plateformes en salariés c'est un
reportage de Jérôme Houbron pour wo TV
la chaîne de la voie du Nord il
au nom du droit des travailleurs ces
huit coursiers indépendants venus
d'Espagne d'Autriche de France ou
d'Italie se sont lancé un défi rallé
Paris à Bruxelles à vélo leur objectif
joindre la capitale belge où une
directive relative au droits des
travailleurs de plateforme est en cours
de discussion les livreurs comptent
dénoncer leurs conditions de travail
quand tu gagnes 5 € de l'URE et ben tu
tu essayes de faire le maximum d'heur
possible sauf que ben tu es confronté à
la pluie au vent à la fatigue jusqu'à
des situations dramatiques on l'a vécu
l'année dernière où un livreur est
décédé parce que trop d'heur on a aucune
protection de sociale les congés malad
les congés payés on on a pas accès on a
pas de réelle cotisation retraite et on
ça fait des années qu'on est traité
n'importe comment et que en fait c'est
un peu le farest pour les plateformes il
faut un cadre légal et il faut surtout
un cadre européen enjeu majeur des
négociations entre le Conseil et le
Parlement européen la possibilité de
requalifier en salarié les travailleurs
de plateforme aujourd'hui considéré
comme indépendant c'est le cas en France
le le Parlement européen a dit oui on
est d'accord pour qu'il y ait une
présomption de salariat Commission
européenne on dit oui on est d'accord
pour qu'il y a une présomption de
salariat et qui bloque qui bloque depuis
des années c'est Emmanuel Macron c'est
Élisabeth Bor quand elle était ministre
du Travail c'est maintenant du SOP
ministre du Travail qui bloque pour que
ça reste ce ce statut qui est pas un
statut d'auto-entrepreneur de la
débrouille avec des droits à rien du
tout après une escale à Amien les
coursiers se rendront à Lille ils
devraient atteindre Bruxelles le 9
novembre
prochain chaque jeudi time to help
association basée en scène Saint-Denis
distribut des paniers repas pour les
personnes dans le besoin sandwich jus de
fruits pommes et bouteille d'eau ce
jeudi d'automne direction l'hôtel de
ville de Paris où des migrants se sont
installés récemment au micro de Mélanie
fort pour notre partenaire minut Mégan
de varieux ne peut qu' constater la
gravité de la situation écoutez ils nous
font comprendre que c'est la seule chose
qu'il vont manger de la journée des fois
peut-être depuis plusieurs jours il y a
eu un mouvement de migrants qui arrivent
en France ils aimeraient être relogé
beaucoup d'entre eux font des demandes
d'asile certains pensent que venir en
France et l'Eldorado et ils sont
malheureusement fortement déçu quand ils
arrivent ici c'est pas possible qu'il y
ait autant de personnes en France qui
manqu de quoi manger
l'opération octobre rose est maintenant
terminée mais pas pour le photographe
troyen Paul Emmanuel qui s'est lancé un
défi celui de réaliser un calendrier au
profit de la lutte contre le cancer 26
femmes m'ont accepté de poser nu et pour
chaque calendrier vendu 20 € seront
reversés à une association locale que
notre partenaire Canal 32 a rencontré
ainsi que ce photographe engagé regardez
Paul Emmanuel spécialisé dans les photos
de bébé s'est lancé pour la première
fois dans la collecte de dons il prépare
un calendrier 20 € seront reversés à la
lutte contre le cancer pour chaque vente
à la base c'est une de mes proches qui a
eu le cancer du sein et qui m'a demandé
de faire une séance photo pour pour
montrer que malgré le cancer on continue
de vivre le soutien fait partie je
trouve de la la guérison voilà on vous
laisse pas tomber on est là et c'est
important d' d'en parler en août il
lance le projet de ce calendrier sur les
réseaux sociaux 26 oboise majeur
acceptent de paraître dénudé dont cndy
clerger une mère de famille de 42 ans en
bonne santé avant la séance photo
l'année dernière j'avais posé pour son
pour l'affiche du cancer du sein sans
avoir été spécialement touché de près
j'arrive en vacances fin juillet je
prends ma douche et puis je sens bah une
grosseur au-dessus le verdict est tombé
comme quoi j'avais un cancer du sein
j'ai une vie normale je fais un peu de
sport je mange normalement enfin voilà
ça vous tombe là on n'est pas prêt à
raison d'une photo par mois chaque
participante pu sélectionner un cliché
je sais plus laquelle a dit c'est un peu
comme les dieux du stade et j'ai dit bah
nous ce sera les DS de l'Aube et ça nous
a bien fait rire du coup on a gardé le
le nom pour le calendrier la vente de
ces calendriers couvrant les années 2024
et 2025 devrait débuter
mi-novembre les recettes seront
reversées à l'association troyenne le
soutien actif qui accompagne les malades
pendant la maladie il y a les médecins
il y a les proches et tout ça et une
fois qu'on est guéri sachant qu'on est
toujours en rémission bah là il y a plus
tellement de soutien et donc c'est pour
ça que les associations comme ça qui
aideent les malades au quotidien je
trouve ça important ce calendrier des
déesses de l'Aube est disponible en
précommande au tarif de 30
€. donner envie aux gens de donner leur
sang et faire de ce don un moment festif
et convivial tel a été l'objectif de
l'Établissement français du sang
Provence Alpe Côte d'Azur Corse pour cet
événement intitulé tout ajaaco donne le
FS a notamment pu compter sur la
participation des chef paâtissier
renommé Jordan Talbo et niikou qui ont
régalé les donneurs avec leur création
pour télépaser Adrien Kouta a rencontré
Tibo Ferrari d'honneur mais aussi vous
allez le voir gourmand ça fait plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois d'ailleurs que
Queen fait je veux donner de mon sang
j'ai pas forcément les infrastructures à
côté de chez moi moi ça me ça me coûte
rien et puis ça apporte beaucoup
apparemment oui moi ça me ça me coûte
absolument rien et puis ça ça apporte
beaucoup donc oui c'est c'est important
nous l'avons tous constaté nos nos
ordinateurs dégagent de la chaleur
parfois au point que nos usages
électroniques dépassent l'impact
environnemental de l'aviation et oui
l'entrepreneur Jean-Baptiste brac a
déposé un brevet proposant une solution
durable de refroidissement des
composants informatiques il espère
maintenant intégrer la french Fab un
reportage de LM TV Sart avec l girira
regardez ça c'est un ordinateur ça aussi
et ça aussi dans ce bureau d'études basé
pour l'instant dans les locaux de la
pépine
in jeanbap ette équipe cré des design
innovants pour des ordinateurs au
système de refroidissement très
performant il rallonge la durée de vie
des composants réduis le bruit tout en
améliorant la performance de la machine
pour vulgariser un petit peu en fait on
fait de la plomberie dans l'ordinateur
et c'est ce qu'on appelle dans la
culture pop le waterol et l'entreprise
travaille le plus possible avec des
acteurs STO pour ces modèles mais
l'équipe veut aller beaucoup plus loin
elle vient de déposer un brevet de bain
à refroidissement qui pourrait carrément
révolutionner le monde de
l'informatique l'immersion cooling donc
la technologie d'immersion des des des
cart
électroniques en définitive c'est notre
technologie support et dessus on a
rajouté des choses permettant de
refroidir beaucoup mieux le système en
fait il y a le décret tertiaire qui va
arriver en 2030 ça dit qu'il faut
baisser la cons ommation énergétique des
bâtiments de 40 % il y a voilà des
leviers qui sont hyper importants
notamment sur les systèmes informatique
l'économie d'énergie que ceux-ci peuvent
engendrer avec des systèmes qui sont
plus responsables Enad s'inscrit donc
dans une démarche durable pour refroidir
les composants dans les grands data
center mais aussi à terme les
ordinateurs des TPE PME
plus voilà tout à fait autre chose au
musée Aéroscopia de Toulouse entre le
Concorde l'Airbus A380 et les multiples
appareils on trouve aussi des objets
volants insolites pour la Dépêche du
Midi mathtis Gardan a accompagné Angel
ménérier responsable des collections
dans les méandres du musée il a
notamment pu voir le cri cri l'un des
avions les plus petits au monde capable
de décoller du toit d'une voiture ou
encore le Xwing tout droit sorti des
films Star Wars entièrement réalisés
vous allez le voir en Lego mais le plus
étonnant c'est bien le Spirit cavarok
cavarok c'est le nom du créateur de de
cet avion c'est un modèle
unique de par sa conception et aussi de
par sa forme il est notamment équipé
d'un plan canard qu'on voit à l'avant
qui est très très grand très
impressionnant ce qui est assez rare sur
sur des avions ce qui fait aussi la
rareté l'originalité et l'aspect
insolide de cette avion c'est qu' en
fait il n'a jamais pu voler réellement
la conception n'était n'étant pas idéal
mais ça en ça reste quand même un avion
qui a été une prouesse de technique et
d'ingénierie la 25e édition du festival
des films pour enfants qui se tenait
dans la métropole de Grenoble a profité
des vacances scolaires pour dévoiler les
secret du cinéma Pif Paf Booum les
enfants se sont prêtés au jeux des
cascades et ont décrypté des scènes
d'action avec de vrais
professionnels del les secrets de
tournage du cinéma ce n'est pas facile
et surtout pour les enfants à l'espace
Aragon de villearbonau les scènes
d'action sont décryptées pour montrer
que dans le cinéma rien n'est laissé au
hasard alors aujourd'hui l'atelier
cascade c'est pour leur leur faire
découvrir la cascade parce que c'est la
cascade essayz aussi de d'enlever ce ce
côté violence en fait qu'on a dans le
cinéma que toute cette violence là en
fait c'est c'est c'est s joué on peut
être cascadeur très jeune grâce à la
cascade on arrive parfois un petit peu à
bah à casser ce côté justement de
violence gratuite non là tu fais
mal la même intensité chute coup de pied
coup de point factice place à la
pratique pour ces mini cascadeurs toutes
les techniques sont bonnes pour éviter
les blessures on a appris comment donner
des coups de PO aux autres sans leur
faire mal comme dans un film j'avoue
c'est très rigolo ça me donne envie de
ressayer en France 500 cascadeurs
exercent maises apprentis ne vont pas
être choisis pour un film ils apprennent
ce qu'est le cinéma dans le cadre de la
25e édition du film pour enfants le but
en fait du festival c'est d'apporter
vraiment une vision assez complète en
ayant les films mais aussi l'envers du
décor des films pourquoi est-ce que en
changeant la caméra de place on peut
avoir un effet qui fonctionne pourquoi
est-ce que ça va pas fonctionner pour le
spectacle ou en tout cas pas de la même
manière donc voilà c'est d'apporter un
peu ces nuances et de montrer que tout
est construit dans dans le cinéma 70
bénévoles et salariés UVR à la fem
fabrication du festival des ateliers de
doublage de création de dessins animés
et des analyses de films sont aussi
prévu pour éveiller les enfants à la
magie du
cinéma restons dans le 7e mars le
festival revisiton n classique était de
retour à Vitel parmi les films projetés
lors de cette 3e édition un saint en
hiver le miroir à deux fA ou encore
l'indémonable tonton flingueur un
événement destiné à rendre éternel les
classiques du cinéma français
ainsi que ces monstres sacrés et comme
chaque année des invités de marque
étaient au rendez-vous de ce festival
comme par exemple Mathias moncorget fils
de Jean Gabin qui a répondu aux
questions de VUG télévision notre
partenaire écoutez on a une chance
formidable lui et moi les enfants de
d'acteur c'est de quand ils sont partis
c'est pouvoir les revoir à bebray quand
tout comme papa ou comme son père
Bourville bah c'est de les voir tous les
15 jours à la télé quoi donc on a
l'impression qu'ils sont toujours là
voilà et puis vous l'avez vu dans les
titres c'est une épice qui vaut de l'or
compteé 30000 € pour 1 kil de safran et
c'est à 500 m d'altitude au pied du mont
Canigou dans les Pyrénées Orientales que
pousse le Crocus sativus cette fleur
contient un pisttile qui deviendra du
safran queill à la main il faut aller
très vite vous allez le voir pour via
occitan Isaac Barry est allé à la
rencontre de Laurent et de sa femme
Safranier depuis 2011 il vend de la
précieuse épice au plus belle table du
département des Pyrénées Orientales
regardez c'est dans une safranière
nichée à 500 m d'altitude au pied du
Canigou que pousse le crocus attivus
cette fleur contient du pisyle qui
deviendra safrant queill à la main il
faut aller très vite c'est une course
contre la montre très vite cette fleur
doit être travaillée c'est la fleur du
jour donc vite vite on va la ramasser
vite vite l'émonder c'està-dire prélever
le pistilLe vite vite la sécher l'
conditionné en bocau et la laissé
maturer 2 mois avant de pouvoir la
consommer une fleur contient un seul
pistile il nous faut pas moins de 200
pistiles pour produire 1 g de safran sec
pur safragé depuis 2011 Laurent et sa
femme distribue les plus belles tables
du département des Pyrénées Orientales
l'épice vaut cher compte 30000 € pour 1
kil c'est en fait c'est pour ces
bienfaits médicinaux qu'il vaut de l'or
voilà c'est cette lecture qu'il faut
avoir c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
toutes les grandes civilisations depuis
l'époque préassyrienne civilisation
d'Europe Nord-Afrique Asie et Occident
Moyen-Orient et Extrême Orient une fois
récolté vient l'étape cruciale de
l'émondage la fleur de crocus je vais
aller la
saigner l'ouvrir avec
l'ongle
évidemment séparer le pisyle et aller le
couper dans le jaune pour éviter tout
déchet végétal le futur safrance sera
les trois fils rouges une phase qui est
longue lesmondages de la fleur met CIN
fois plus de temps que LAAC cuueillette
après les pistiles sont séchés et mis en
bocau pour les laisser vieillir et
devenir saffran naissant il va être
assez rond fruité sucré très jeune plus
apte de la pâtisserie on va laisser
passer quelques années par exemple 2 3
ans 4 ans 5 ans et il pourra convenir
sur du poisson comme un vin exactement
la France produit dizaine de kilos d'or
rouge par an au 19e siècle le pays était
l'un des principaux producteurs mondiaux
de safran avec plus de 30 tonnes chaque
année le lendemain de la toussin et
jusqu'au 25 décembre des chantés Noël
sont organisés aux antiguyane et en
France hexagonale par les communautés
ultramarines ces champsmélan profanes et
sacrés sont issu d'anciennes chansons
populaire médiévale française de Noël
chaque cantique est agrémenté de
refrains en créole rythmé par des les
influences de Bigin de maurka de Vals
CRÉO ou de zouuk pour via ATV ha siul
tidas et Axel guitau nous font partager
cette première soirée festive en
Martinique
regardez début novembre mais l'ambiance
de Noël est déjà
enclenchée le groupe les trouadour ouvre
le bal avec la première soirée chanté
Noël de l'année elle s'est déroulée chez
Corin au François vu que maintenant le
Noël B et a plutôt disparu donc on
s'adapte à cette tradition de groupe de
différents groupes de Noël qui chantent
un peu partout et qui passent un peu
dans toutes les communes qui véhiculent
le Noël de cette façon les champs
traditionnels ont été repris à tu tête
par les invités de quoi préparer ses
cordes vocales pour les prochains jours
ça attire de plus en plus tout
simplement parce qu'on a eu une baisse
par rapport aux deux années ou tro
années où nous étions confiné et
effectivement ben la ferveur revient
elle revient avec avec un dynamisme
incroyable loin des chantter Noël
traditionnel dans nos rues ou à la
maison celui-ci est organisé et plaît au
public nous avons une cent forcment de
plus en plus exigeante elle a besoin de
choses de qualité et nous travaillons
dans ce sens c'est vrai que c'est une
association mais trouad dépense des sous
répète crée fait des tenues TB vraiment
a un budget pour lancer à chaque fois sa
saison les fesités ontmarr prép vos
livrets de chant et votre bonne
humeur voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires au revoir à tous à
[Musique]
bientôt